there's lots of things about the world
under Donald Trump that make me despair
for Humanity or that make me worried or
that shocked me or surprised me or
whatever else but one of the things that
I really just straight-up
resent about the Trump administration is
that it's forcing us to have to
re-explain and a lot of really simple
concepts that I previously thought we
sort of had a pretty firm grasp on that
have apparently been thrown out the
window under Donald Trump so for example
tariffs I talked yesterday about tariffs
extensively China and Mexico don't pay
for Donald Trump's tariffs the American
companies and the American people who
import the stuff from China and Mexico
are the ones actually paying for the
tariffs voter fraud we just talked about
it in the first segment today doesn't
matter what Trump and his followers say
in-person voter fraud to the to the tune
of these three to five million illegal
votes Donald Trump claims took place in
2016
doesn't exist okay we've talked about it
all Brennan Center for Justice study we
know it's just not real and we're having
to re-explain this under Donald Trump I
could go on and give you a long list but
I want to focus in on one specific one
today which is that under Trump since
Trump's tax reform plan was put in place
all of a sudden people are pretending
that his tax cut would go to the middle
class and that the part that goes to the
rich is also good because it gives the
economy more juice so to speak there's
this idea that giving tax cuts to the
rich stimulates the economy it trickles
down all of that stuff we've already
dealt with this okay I've been dealing
with it for years we've been dealing
with it on the program most recently we
dealt with it under george w bush tax
cuts for the rich aren't particularly
stimulative to the economy and
Republican tax plans mostly give
disproportionate amounts of money to the
rich and to big corporations no matter
what they tell you and once again that's
what happened with the Trump Republican
tax reform that was passed during Donald
Trump's first term there's a really
great report from the Congressional
Research Service called the economic
effects of the 2017 tax revision
preliminary observations you might
remember we were told it would be great
for all Americans we were told it would
let makers
their money it would incentivize
businesses to invest more in their
businesses and in their employees which
would cause wages to rise it would
stimulate economic growth we were told
that even though in the short-term it
would reduce the amount of money that
the government takes in that it would
very quickly pay for itself because of
all the growth and winning in all of
this that would be created and
ultimately the government would actually
be taking in more money
none of it has happened wages have
continued to increase slowly but they're
increasing at the same rate that they
were increasing before the tax reform
plan went into effect growth has
continued on the same trend line as
before
the tax reform plan but what did happen
as a result of Trump's tax plan is lower
the effective tax rate for the
super-rich by a significant percentage
and hugely in terms of the raw dollars
that went back to the very rich relative
to the middle class and the lower middle
class and the poor
so Trump personally and his friends made
out really really well from this tax
plan what it did do was cause businesses
to use the money not to reinvest in
their own businesses or employees but to
start repurchasing shares of their own
stock to drive up the price which again
is a way of using the money from the tax
cuts to mostly help their big
shareholders and their executives it's
almost like we knew this would happen
when they first started talking about
this type of tax reform because this is
how it happens every single time and I
want to be really clear this is not me
speaking out against the tax plan
because I'm jealous that the tax plan
was bad for me and good for other people
this tax reform was very good for me
okay I did a whole segment several
months ago when I had filed my taxes
explaining how even though the david
pakman show grew from 2017 to 2018 my
effective tax rate as the majority owner
of the David Pakman show
went down from 26% effective federal tax
rate for the 2017 tax year 26% down to
under 22% in 2018 I'll take the money
okay
but my point in talking about that in
talking about it again here is that it
is not economically stimu
in terms of policy to do the type of tax
reform that saves me like 15% on taxes
four out of 26 is roughly about 15% and
disproportionately more going to the
very very rich in corporations who are
saving the money who are using the money
to repurchase to do stock buybacks etc
last thing we call these the Trump tax
cuts but really their Republican tax
cuts so if you're not happy with the tax
reform plan
yes Trump is to blame and yes Trump
should be voted out in 2020 he supported
the tax plan he worked on the tax plan
with the Republicans but it's the
Republicans who wrote it and actually
pushed it through in the House and
Senate who are also responsible and they
should also be voted out in 2020 really
important not to forget that and blame
this all on Trump because it is much
much bigger than Donald Trump let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show i've got a nice announcement
coming up later on the show today i hope
you'll stay with us if you love learning
new things you probably want to check
this out
the david pakman show today is sponsored
by Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started
for free by clicking the link under this
video